this video has just gone viral
of
an intruder making it to some fashion
show where he walks down the runway
wearing a plastic bag before a security
guard stops him
there he is you guys got a shower cap on
he's got some kind of plastic bag or
Poncho and then he's strutting and then
finally a security guard takes him down
and the reason this is going viral I
don't know when this was shot I don't
know where this was shot but the reason
it's going viral is not because of the
the guy this was a good prank he pulled
it off well it's because the audience
looks completely non-plussed
so yeah there it is there's High fashion
and we all know this even if this were
just as sketch on and Saturday Night
Live or something we've all seen this
happen before where some Modern artists
will show something that's not beautiful
that's not particularly intricate that a
three-year-old could have put together
in two seconds and
because of the I don't know the
pretensions of the artist and of our
culture you'll have otherwise serious
you know well-dressed wealthy Elite
people looking at it trying to pretend
as though there's some deeper meaning or
that it's in some way aesthetically
pleasing how does this happen
this is what happens when art in a
society ceases to be connected to Beauty
right now go to ramp.com Knowles are you
looking for a better way to simplify
your business finances across expenses
vendor payments and accounting if so
ramp could be a complete game changer
for your business ramp
is a corporate card and expense
management software designed to help you
save time and money with ramp you can
issue cards to every employee with
limits and restrictions and automate
expense reporting so you can stop
wasting time at the end of every month
ramps accounting software automatically
collects receipts and categorizes your
expenses in real time so you don't have
to the time that you will save each
month on employee expenses will allow
you to close your books eight times
faster businesses that use Ram save an
average of 3.5 percent within the first
year ramp is easy to use get started in
less than 15 minutes whether you've got
five or five thousand employees right
now get 250 when you join ramp go to
ramp.com Knowles
cards issued by Sutton Bank and Celtic
Bank members FDIC terms and conditions
apply the reason that this guy
was able to walk down the runway in a
plastic bag and have people take that
seriously as as high fashion is because
art
for at least 100 years now has not been
connected to Beauty any longer art has
become
critical uh self-referential ironic and
and really just a form of anti-art a
deconstruction of art you see this most
clearly with an artist like Marcel
Duchamp he's the modern artist who put a
urinal in the middle of the floor and
said this is a work of art the fountain
by the way I say this as a modern artist
I I don't want to toot my own horn here
folks I am one of the most prominent
modern artists in the world today my
modern art piece reasons to vote for
Democrats a comprehensive guide
a number one best-selling blank book
that continues to sell oodles and
noodles of copies
that is a work of Modern Art that is a
deconstruction of the form of the book
and I yeah I'm a regular martial Duchamp
but I'm a regular Damien Hurst but
with all of those artists I get a kick
out of some of the work of like a Damien
Hurst who I mean he's got all these
weird works of art like a big shark and
formaldehyde or you know polka dots or
whatever or even Michelle Duchamp with
the urinal
but it's purely an intellectual and
critical Endeavor it's it's critical
it's not artistic it's not beautiful
when you disconnect from the
transcendentals
the good the true and the Beautiful You
are left in this morass of relativism
According to which you don't know if a
guy wearing a garbage bag is really
wearing high fashion
and in that Society because we we know
that it's not beautiful we're not
attracted to it in any way we just have
to take our cues from everybody else you
kind of find yourself looking around you
is that person taking the art seriously
and then you convince yourself that ugly
works of art are actually beautiful and
worth lots of money
that's a society that's much more
volatile and I think it helps to explain
from the artistic angle some of the
political volatility that we're seeing
that was that was less common in earlier
ages of our country and our civilization
because we're not grounding our views
and our behaviors in anything objective
and real anymore the good the true and
the Beautiful are objective they're
unchanging we can discourse rationally
about them this kind of crap the modern
art and the wearing garbage bags around
and urinals pretending to be fine works
of sculpture
there's nothing objective about that
it's all socially contextualized it's
all contingent on the feelings of the
people in the room which can change
rapidly because man's passions are wild
and the imagination of man's heart is
evil from the beginning expect more
volatility the more crazy kooky art we
get there's a new study out
very helpful to the pro-life cause and
very helpful to poor little babies who
are being targeted by liberals
it knocks down a lie that we've heard
which is that abortion is not painful to
babies abortion is not painful to babies
at a certain point it becomes painful
and when the when the babies are capable
of pain then maybe we'll have some
restrictions on but early on in
pregnancy it's just not painful so just
we can poison them and chop them up and
they don't feel any pain and that's
obviously not true and I think we all
know intuitively that's not true well
we've got a study now that backs it up
it's called reconsidering fetal pain
by two medical professionals Stuart
Derbyshire and John C Bachmann
what the study says is fetal pain has
long been a contentious issue
in large purpose fetal pain is often
cited as a reason to restrict access to
termination of pregnancy or abortion
very clinical language but he says we
have Divergent views regarding the
morality of abortion but have come
together to address the evidence for
fetal pain so they're saying look
whether we don't we're not both
pro-lifers we're not both pro-bars we
have different views on abortion but
we're just addressing do these babies
actually feel pain and they say at 12
weeks gestation there were the first
projections from the thalamus into the
cortical subplate and then they use a
bunch of scientific jargon to explain
how we think that pain
begins much much later in pregnancy but
actually no it doesn't as people think
now begin around 24 weeks it probably
starts around 12 weeks gestation
and so what the conclusion is fetal
analgesia and anesthesia should thus be
standard for abortions in the second
trimester especially after 18 weeks when
there is good evidence for functional
connection from the peripheral into the
brain so this is an amazing conclusion
what they're saying is look
we used to think there was pain starting
at 24 weeks that the babies would feel
the pain now we think it could be as
early as 12 weeks and it certainly as
early as 18 weeks so when you murder
your baby at 12 to 24 weeks give them an
anesthetic
and then chop them up or poison them or
inject him full of saline solution but
but when you're about to murder your
child just know he's in excruciating
pain so you're going to want to give him
an anesthetic before you chop him up
um
what what woman
maybe some psychopath doctor you know
doctor abortionist doesn't care about
any of that but what mother is going to
say wait my baby feels pain
so okay if I'm gonna have to give him an
anesthetic so I can kill him well if I
give him anesthetic he sounds kind of
like a person
because people feel pain so it doesn't
feel just like a clump of cells anymore
maybe I shouldn't kill my kid
now what's amazing here is the
fact of whether or not a baby in the
womb feels pain should not be all that
morally relevant
there are people who can't feel pain
they're still people they we still
shouldn't murder them the question is is
this baby a baby is this a human being
is this a live person
one of the uh aspects of being a living
person is that you feel pain often and
mo much of the time you are capable of
feeling pain but that shouldn't actually
matter to the moral question of whether
or not it's right to kill an innocent
little baby whether he feels pain or not
and yet it is relevant politically it is
relevant because as a friend of mine
says facts don't care about your
feelings but politics I will complicate
the phrasing politics largely cares
about your feelings
and the science here is on our side and
the science doesn't just exist in a
vacuum
our bodies don't just exist in a vacuum
the facts of this world don't exist in a
vacuum the physical facts of this world
imply certain metaphysical things and
moral things and they pull on our
heartstrings for good reason and this is
all the more reason for the
conservatives as we get a new generation
of leadership and we stop being so
squishy to get even tougher on these
laws and stand up for objective truth so
we don't live in a subjectivist
relativistic civilization where we've
got urinals all over the floors
pretending to be art boy what a great
clip that was now but but make sure that
you ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael Noel Show podcast and show and
channel and clips we'll see you next
time